bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8 sur tv
fil 78 de votre rendez vous quotidien
avec l'actualité locale nous sommes le
12 mars il est 18 heures si vous nous
rejoignez en direct comme chaque soir
dans un instant sur ce plateau gilles
becker elle c'est le jardinier en chef
du domaine nationale de saint germain en
laye avec lui nous parlerons des 400 ans
de la naissance d'andré le nôtre
l'architecte paysager qui a signé
notamment les jardins du château de
versailles mais aussi les jardins du
domaine de saint germain en laye même si
la météo ne s'y prête pas beaucoup nous
continuerons suite à parler jardinage
avec julie rocha soir heisbourg soir
julie c'est pas un temps à jardiner et
pour autant quelques conseils avec vous
pour parler paillage tout à fait ils ont
converti en quoi consiste cette
technique avec stéphane loriot qui sera
avec nous d'une manière un peu original
en interview vidéo alors né vous dans
quelques minutes pour cette chronique de
l'environnement à noter que je recevrai
également ce soir le délégué local de la
cfe cgc le syndicat qui va signer
l'accord de compétitivité proposé par la
direction de renault quelles
conséquences pour les salariés nous le
verrons avec lui et puis comme chaque
soir les reportages de la rédaction
voici d'ailleurs un aperçu avec les
principaux titres en images de ce 12
mars les conséquences de la neige et
surtout du verglas difficultés de
circulation sur les routes et dans les
transports en commun le point dans le
département dans l'agglomération de 50
ans nine et nous verrons également les
prévisions climatiques à venir avec
météo france
ils étaient nombreux ce lundi soir au
palais des congrès de versailles pour le
lancement français du nouveau jeu vidéo
de la société blizzard starcraft 2 une
société internationale dont le siège
français justement installé dans la cité
royale le 12 mars date anniversaire des
400 ans de la naissance et du plus
célèbre paysagiste de france andré le
nôtre
vous le disait il ya quelques instants
une série de manifestations culturelles
vont s'étaler pendant toute l'année 2013
et qui ont été présentés aujourd'hui
et puis un site d'entraînement
d'exception pour thomas bach aucune le
grand canal du château de versailles
vous le voyez en images les revenus des
jo de londres le rameur vient de
décrocher une médaille de bronze lors
des championnats de france indoor il se
prépare pour décrocher les sélections
aux championnats d'europe
des chutes de neige exceptionnelles pour
la saison cela devrait durer jusqu'à
mercredi matin avec plus de dix
centimètres déjà par endroits au sol le
trafic est fortement perturbé dans
département matignon a même activé la
cellule interministérielle de crise
rappelons que 29 départements sont en
alerte orange neige et verglas en
l'espace de deux jours le thermomètre a
perdu une quinzaine de degrés une
situation exceptionnelle qui n'a pas
surpris les automobilistes ce matin tu
as été salée mais avec skis et ski et en
tomber dessus surtout sur l'a86 vers
vélizy la salle de vente et de la
livraison mais j'ai un petit peu de
retard
bah ouais c'est on peut pas tenir
vraiment là
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines est plutôt épargné par les
flocons
un salage a été effectuée cette nuit dès
4 heures du matin second préventif à 20
heures les voies saint-quentinoise sont
restés dégager toute la journée sans que
la chaussée soit trop glissante mais
certains automobilistes avaient anticipé
le gel je prend la précaution quand la
télé nous avisent d'un de neige et de
verglas
l'huile et les caoutchoucs de portières
une chance que n'a pas eue la région de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines l'autoroute
a10 est fermée dans les deux sens
jusqu'à jarnier à cause d'un accident
côté transports la sncf conseille aux
usagers de ne pas se rendre à paris ce
mardi le trafic sur la ligne u est
interrompue depuis ce matin et de
nombreux trains ont été supprimés sur la
ligne c du rer en secours certains
courageux ont préféré prendre le vélo
pour se déplacer se déplace eh oui mais
donc prudemment en raison de la neige
des phénomènes météo répétitif depuis le
début de l'hiver les yvelines ont connu
26 jours de neige contre 15 pour un
hiver moyen
le département a même connu cette année
six jours consécutifs de poudreuse entre
le 18 et le 23 janvier
ce qui est marquant cette année ce sont
les températures ce mardi après midi on
ne dépassait pas les moins deux degrés
on pourrait même frôlé le record de mars
1971 avec - 10,5 degrés enregistrés on
attend pour l'année prochaine et en
début de matinée demain des températures
de l'ordre de - 7 à -10 degrés la
semaine dernière on avait un flux de sud
qui nous amenait des températures très
douces et là en ce début de semaine
y'avait l'anticyclone qui était situé
entre l'islande et
la scandinavie a amené en fait une masse
d'air très froide qui venaient du nord
de l'allemagne qui est venu par la
belgique
les températures devraient rester froide
mercredis et jeudis vendredis matin à
noter un épisode de pluies verglaçantes
1re d'où est attendu pour ce week end
avec des températures comprises entre 4
et 8 degrés plus proches des normales de
saison et l'arrivée des traditionnelles
giboulées de mars et actuellement la
nationale 118 est coupée à hauteur de
meudon en direction de la province il y
à 37 km de bouchons sur les routes
d'ile-de-france vigilance orange qui est
maintenue jusqu'à 6h ce matin et on
passe tout de suite à la chronique de
l'environnement nous sommes mardi avec
jeu lire sa soirée s'en va parler
jardinage tout à fait plus précisément
paillage avec parce que j'ai rencontré
stéphane loriot donc le paillage c'est
sa spécialité c'est une technique
naturelles pour nourrir les sols la
terre sous la forme de couverture
végétale isolante d'environ 10 cm
d'épaisseur
malheureusement il n'a pu être avec nous
ce soir mais il nous a reçus avec elodie
moines dans son jardin à chevreuse
on lui a demandé sa philosophie du
paillage le paillage litière du sol
c'est la même chose
redonner au sol ce qui sort du sol
retour à la forêt nourrir le sol pour
nourrir les plantes
il ya plein de phrases comme ça qu'ils
peuvent nous expliquer le plus produite
le processus simple le processus naturel
dans un jardin on récupère l'eau il faut
le faire dans un jardin on composte il
faut le faire lorsque je récupère l'eau
je vais du point à leurs récupérateur
d'eau vers le point b la plante je fais
un aller retour lorsque je composte je
coupe une plante dans le jardin je
taille jetons ou ce genre de paramètres
font à le jardin au point b le
composteur au bout d'un an j'ai dû
composent penser la plante a baissé
ensuite vous avez le prototype ou le ce
que nous propose en termes de déchets
verts se sont ni ni ni des déchets ni
donner du verre attitude je dirais donc
la poche kraft qui va sur le trottoir là
c'est terrible points à le jardin point
b la poche kraft le trottoir coincer le
camion qui va transporter ces végétaux
vers un sens du compostage financée par
nos impôts
ensuite
du point des verts le sens du compostage
point e si j'ai bonne mémoire le
bricomarché ou la jardinerie avec point
f votre maison point g la jardinerie et
pour de nouveau au point y faisait j'en
perds mon alphabet retour au jardin donc
là vous avez cette espèce de parcours
incroyable de ces végétaux qui pour moi
n'a pas de sens évidemment donc tout ce
qui sort du sort de verdun retournent
directement dans votre jardin et vous
êtes dupont à faire le point et là
effectivement il n'ya plus de compostage
systématique il n'y a plus de deux
récupérateurs d'eau systématique le
récupérateur d'eau utilisées pour la
chasse d'eau la bonne affaire je la rose
quasiment plus vous avez un humus en
place aux gouvernants pour faire court
et là effectivement moins travail plus
de résultats et des plantes en plein
dans plein de santé qui se défend très
très bien dans différentes attaques
d'où qu'elles viennent il avait des
arbres qui est attaqué par un champignon
pathogène
grâce à la mycorhize grâce au paillage
j'ai eu un arbre qui a eu des défenses
immunitaires évidemment il ya plus
celui-là pu contenir une maladie qui
allait tuer l'arbre et l'arbre a pu se
défendre tout simplement
donc on l'a vu stéphane loriot prône les
circuits courts pour préserver la bonne
santé de sa flore on va voir que l'on
peut créer différents types de pays le
plus répandu est à base de copeaux de
bois appelée brf bois raméal fragmenté
et les autres sont constitués de
plusieurs éléments végétaux stéphane
curieux nous explique tout ça alors le
pai est le plus connu la litière le plus
connu c'est le bois raméal fragmenté
bien sûr qu' à ce qu'ils fassent ce
qu'ils nous proposent qu'il ya de
meilleur c'est vraiment du cinq étoiles
mais la ressource n'est pas illimité
bien sûr il ya un coup il ya de la
machine derrière tout ça également vous
pouvez vous en procurer de manière ou
d'une autre avec votre propre au voyeur
ou vous l'acheter c'est chez des
professionnels mais la ressource faut
bien comprendre n'est pas et limiter nos
forêts ne sont pas une aeternam et dans
un jardin n'importe lequel votre jardin
est un bocage en puissance entre les
haies et les arbres que vous allez
tailles et toutes ses branches et tous
ces rameaux vous leur mettez au sol et
c'est ce que pratiquent les pays
émergents ce moment pour se débarrasser
de la dette des ogm
bref vivre chichement mais de manière
digne et grâce à ces méthodes
grâce à ce blocage grâce à cette
agroforesterie vous pouvez dans votre
jardin pratiquer la même quasiment la
même chose évidemment donc tout ce qui
va être tondu taille et sylvain ton du
sud pour ces gens là c'est difficile
mais tout ce qui coupait taille et
retourne au sol pour le principe
évidemment
mon outil de jardinage c'est
principalement sécateur et puis mon
bateau pour faire court c'est plutôt ça
et donc je pratique également le
paillage sauvage évidemment et les
feuilles à 100 de bon aloi
les branches locales viennent les
feuilles ou plutôt la legal des
graminées ou tout ce qui touche au moins
pelouse
vous aurez plutôt de la zot plutôt des
bactéries qui vont travailler et pour
les branches vous aurait plutôt vu comme
le champignon pour les plantes vivaces
ou bisannuelles vivace et au pied d'un
fruitiers comme ces deux arbres là on
mettra plutôt du bois des préférences et
des feuilles évidemment alors pour les
pays organique on peut également
utiliser des coques de fruits types de
noix et noisettes leur durée de
décomposition varie alors et est un peu
plus longue pour rentrer dans la terre
on vous donne quelques conseils de
jardinage même si effectivement on la
météo ne s'y prête pas pour les
prochains jours mais le printemps va
revenir c'est une certitude est ce qu'il
ya des avantages alors à pratiquer le
paillage alors stéphane leurs yeux nous
a parlé d'économie en tout genre on
écoute déjà une colo 8 ans une économie
d'énergie je la place souvent c'est
cette formule moins de travailler plus
de résultats une économie d'eau
remarquable évidemment comme on dirait
une colle parfois en plein coeur de
l'été pendant les sécheresses ici vous
avez des fissures là où on marche et la
soul page vous mettez votre main le sol
est bien bien tendres il est frais il
arrose et parfois mais c'est très très
rare et on peut estimer que pendant un
mois on peut laisser le jardin livré à
lui même en pleine sécheresse si c'était
le cas mais grâce au paillage du sol on
n'est pas des fruitiers j'ai eu si un
arbre qui est mort de nos de sécheresse
tout simplement comme c'était le cas
dans toute la saison il ya quelques
années mais grâce au paillage on un
jardin qui qui vit en autonomie
véritable enfin sans aucune espèce
d'apport de nutriments et de flotte là
vous êtes vraiment autonome dans le sens
large large du terme
en plus sans aucun auxiliaires
évidemment vous êtes vraiment que je
d'auxiliaires je parle d aide plutôt des
intermédiaires à qui vous vous rendez
vous propose des choses en terme de
comportement et de produits là vous avez
tout sur place et bâtiments et les
autres chinois je voulais parler des
insectes auxiliaires que vous avez dans
votre jardin également avec des tas de
pierres en tas de bois et des plantes
qui attire la sienne notamment qu'ils
étaient filmés entier pucerons vous avez
dans un jardin les coccinelles à côté
est une sacrée feignante ça c'est les
gens le savent peu mais vous avez trois
fois plus d'auxiliaires dans un jardin
enfin un trophée plus d'auxiliaires que
le prédateur
tout simplement les auxiliaires voulait
fabriquer vous les voulez vous les
attirer et le reste suivra donc dans un
jardin il faut être
il faut être plutôt un chef d'orchestre
plutôt qu'un musicien et donner toutes
les billes nécessaire qui existe déjà de
fait dans son jardin pour que tous ces
charmants musiciens puissent travailler
pour la globalité d'un jardin en pleine
santé on va dire laisser faire la nature
voilà le message à retenir cela implique
parfois d'avoir un jardin un peu sauvage
on son jardin d'ailleurs à stéphane
loriot c'est un peu la jungle un peu ça
peut paraître un peu fouillis mais en
fait pas du tout c'était réfléchi
oui voilà fléchi d'accord bon c'est vrai
que ça paraît comme ça un petit peu
brouillon mais oui il va nous expliquer
pourquoi dans le quartier ici mon jardin
passe pour ce qu'il ya de plus comment
dire négligence qui a de plus comment
dire oui c'est le terme délit gens alors
que je sais que chez moi c'est vivant
j'ai de la chaîne alimentaire j'ai un
sol plus vivant ici chez moi le sol sans
grade chez mes voisins le sol se dégrade
chez moi n'y a pas de battement s'il
n'ya pas d'érosion et donc effectivement
le
je suis perçu comme le feignant du
quartier mais les années 60 c'est fini
courber l'échiné pour constamment être
un un stakhanoviste du du rendement et
du résultat à 100% ça ne m'intéresse
plus on aura toujours 5% de pertes dont
95 95 % de réussite
de quoi se plaint-on évidemment et le
paillage sauvage c'est ça et
effectivement la pelouse tondue au
cordeau là est tondue au cordeau cela ne
me concerne le plus prompt et encore
j'ai des gamins traumatisés parce c'est
le kent flingué par ce parce jardin
impeccable là c'est tout ça c'est
terminé et je ne traite plus jeunes
intervient quasiment plus ou quoi que ce
soit je laisse la nature travaillaient
pour elle même et le reste suivra
évidemment bien sûr stéphane loriot est
un jardinier rebelles laisse faire la
nature
alors on a vu que la technique du
paillage et est accessible à tous
puisqu'il faut très peu de matériaux et
elle peut se mettre en place à n'importe
quelle saison puisque c'est un anti
extrême remarquable pour reprendre les
termes de stéphane loriot un an ti cho
un anti froid un anti siècle un anti
humide
pour ceux qui hésitent encore il a un
dernier argument burnand le paillage
permet de sélectionner les plantes
sauvages de les arracher très facilement
une fois que j'ai raté ma plante sauvage
mais je la remets au sol directement
donc j'ai payé c'est l'émotion
et puis l'autre je la garde et chez les
plantes sauvages vous avez certaines qui
vont attirer des insectes auxiliaires
évidemment vous découvrez des fleurs
inconnu au bataillon pourquoi pas mais
en tout cas vous les sélectionner et
vous arrachez très très bien si c'est le
quart est celle que vous choyer que vous
gardez le ballon voulait mangerez elles
ont des feuilles encore plus belle et
plus grande et donc ce jardin là est
interactif en termes de bas je me suis
retrouvé parfois le soir à prendre ma
lampe de poche pour chercher des feux du
pissenlit qui manquait pour moi salades
c'est rigolo mais c'est aussi subtile
pour moi ça me semble parle tout ça le
paillage permet donc de créer un jardin
en autosuffisance à moindre frais sont
trop d'interventions humaines des
communes se sont déjà emparés de cette
technique c'est le cas de saint rémy les
chevreuse qui stocke actuellement 15
mètres cubes de copeaux de bois le
fameux brf qu'elle utilise en litière
pour les plantes ornementales de ces
lieux publics peut être un exemple à
suivre
et puisque l'on parle de bois on va en
voir une utilisation ludique avec les
fameuses planchettes de bois en cat
larmes
d'impressionnantes bâtissant cap là de
simples planches est en pin des landes
la maison de l'environnement à magny les
hameaux a proposé aux enfants pendant
les vacances
un atelier de construction avec ses
pièces animé par le centre capela de
paris l'atelier a invité également les
parents à participer tour eiffel trains
maisons l'architecturé adaptée à tous
les âges et on en installe une base et
on les guide au fur et à mesure nos sacs
au début ils savent pas trop vim après
ce qui est pratique c'est qu'une fois
qui a déjà des constructions il voit et
ils ont envie aussi de réaliser des
choses aussi impressionnante que les
autres et à partir de là ça les motive
plus de 22000 plancher en bois étaient à
la disposition des enfants
le kapla fait appel aussi bien à la
logique quelle imagination parents et
grands parents n'ont pas hésité à
emmener les enfants à l'atelier pour
l'accompagner pendant cette découverte
d'une nouvelle activité surtout thomas
d'utiliser le bois
voilà ce qui était intéressant de voir
cet atelier ludique à développer la
réflexion et la dextérité manuelle les
enfants il a permis également de
peut-être susciter des vocations de
bâtisseur j'aime bien la construction
qu'est ce que tu aimerais construire
pas des trucs hauts des bas des trucs
qu'on peut faire
vous n'êtes pas coiffée
et l'occasion pour lés parents de
partager un moment de loisir avec leurs
enfants et aussi de se prendre un but et
la chronique de l'environnement qui se
poursuit à présent avec l'agenda
oui alors encore une seule date à
retenir cette semaine je rappelle donc
l'exposition habitat écologique de la
théorie à la pratique se tient jusqu'au
samedi 23 mars à la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux
en visite libre de 14 heures à 18 heures
et je précise que le magazine équilibre
diffusé ce vendredi est consacré à l'éco
construction
merci julie le 7 8 qui donc se poursuit
toujours en direct entre 18 et 19h sur
tv films nous parlons jeu vidéo tout à
l'heure nous parlons aussi de l'accord
de compétitivité signé entre elles les
syndicats et la direction de renault
mais tout de suite on s'intéresse notre
fait du jour le 400e anniversaire de la
naissance d'andré le nôtre